Hi, I'm Allison Powell and I am an actor/
filmmaker. And today I'm going to be talking
to you about one of the hardest lessons
that I had to learn when I was starting
out as a filmmaker as a producer and
that is something that I'm still working
on in my daily life and it is the
ability to admit that you don't know how
to do something and being vulnerable
enough and confident enough to ask for
help so I always tell people now my
three favorite word's on a film set
are I don't know and those three words
can actually be incredibly hard to say
especially when you're just starting out
and you want people to think that you've
got this you're smart you're confident
you know what you're doing they can
trust you they definitely should have
hired you you're dependable but in
reality not everyone on a set can know
everything you can't know how to do
everything like that would just be
insane and so I started out pretending
that I knew what something meant or what
a piece of equipment was or I'd go away
for ten minutes and maybe try to do
whatever they asked me to do or what I
thought they asked me to do and then I
would come back and just say yeah it's
not working or I couldn't find it or I
can't figure it out and for some reason
I thought it was better to kind of lie
in these situations rather than just
being upfront and saying I don't know
what that is or I don't know how to do
that or I don't know who that is and
just asking for help it's a really
really difficult thing to do that I
don't think a lot of people realize and
not enough people talk about it takes
actually an incredible amount of
confidence to admit to someone that you
don't know something and and or that you
need help and I think it's a really
important skill set for new filmmakers
to learn and to embrace because the only
way that you're going to learn how to do
something is by admitting that you don't
already know how to do it so now I do
that on almost every film set I'm on and
I try to do it more in my day
life as well so for example we were
doing some pickup shots for my feature
and they were driving so the DP built a
whole camera rig on top of a car he
brought you at everything in plays with
ratchet straps and then at the end of
the day when we were breaking stuff down
and I was helping out with that I just
said to the AC who was working next to
me I said I don't know how to take off
ratchet straps so I'm gonna watch you do
it and then you're gonna watch me do it
and then I'll know how and what was so
funny is he turned to me and he said I
don't know how to take off ratchet
straps either and I had just assumed
because he seemed have more experience
in the camera department than me maybe
because he was a guy I just assumed that
he would know how to do it and what was
great is he just admitted right to me
that he didn't know how to do it either
so both of us had to go to the DP and
say hey we don't really know how to do
this
one of the first shorts that I was on as
a producer and part of a producing team
I said to the producer who was filling
in all of the sag paperwork for us I
said can i watch you fill it out and I
just stood looking over her shoulder as
she filled in everything and she went to
the actors and have them fill out their
contracts because I didn't know how to
do it and I wanted to learn the only way
that you will learn is by asking for
help and admitting that you don't know
how to do something and I want you to
really embrace these words I don't know
when you're on set embrace your
vulnerability as a filmmaker I think
people think and I certainly used to
think that it was a sign of weakness to
admit that you didn't know how to do
something and people would fire me they
would think I didn't belong they would
not ask me to do anything in the future
and the total opposite happens people
get more excited they want to teach you
they want to help you they want you to
expand your knowledge base so that then
the next time they ask you or the next
time they want to hire you for a project
you already know the shorthand you know
what they're asking you to do when you
embrace that vulnerability you also make
people want to work with you if you just
Marche around acting like you know
everything and know how to do everything
people don't like that it's gonna be
arrogant it's gonna turn people off if
instead you ask for help or offer help
when it's needed people are going to
want to be around that type of energy so
being vulnerable is a great way to get
people on your side and I say being
vulnerable but it's really being
confident it's really having the
confidence to be vulnerable and say I
don't know those are the three best
words on a film set it also is really
important to remember that that could be
a safety concern if you don't know how
to do something or don't know what a
piece of equipment is or how to use it
you need to say that you will not get in
trouble you will get in trouble if you
pretend that you know how to do it and
somebody gets injured or something gets
broken or a lot of time is lost and so
again it's just better to have that
confidence to be vulnerable upfront and
say you don't know how to do something
and then either learn or observe so that
the next time you can do it but onset is
not the place to pretend that you know
everything pretend that you tried to go
and do something to come back and lie
about it which is what I definitely used
to do it's the place to say hey I don't
know how to do this but I'm here to
learn and I'm willing to learn and I
want you to show me so that I know how
to do it tomorrow or on the next project
and that is my secret weapon as a
filmmaker
it's how I learned everything I know
pretty much is by having the confidence
to be vulnerable and go up to someone
and say I don't know how to do that can
i watch you can you show me can you talk
me through it so if you want to become a
better filmmaker have the confidence to
be vulnerable ask for help and admit you
don't know thanks for watching